bonjour donna kesselman merci beaucoup
d'être avec vous ce matin en direct sur
rt france les travailleurs d'amazon sont
en train aux états unis sont en train de
voter pour éventuellement mettre en
place un syndicat
en quoi est ce une première au sein du
groupe amazon et autres meyrin sein de
groupe amazon chez un employeur sinon
donc anti syndicale qui dépensent 10
mille dollars qu'un jour dans les
méthodes qu'on connaît vous états unis
pour casser le syndicat mais s'il vrai
aussi de la grande distribution par
exemple chez walmart etc
mais entre autres c'est aussi le dessus
de faire c'est à tomber le bastion anti
syndicale du sud qui serait très
important pour tout le mouvement ouvrier
en général
pourquoi le luth et aimer les 10 ou
d'autres raisons aussi le premièrement
le corps n'avait réussi parce que comme
c'était indiqué il ya eu des grèves dans
les usines des maisons dans le new york
contre le fait que les conditions
sanitaires n'ont pas été respectées et
surtout contre les unit gay hérité cette
usine qui est 85% noir a reçu le soutien
de blake lively matters aux états unis
du syndicat national des joies de paul
donc ça devient un lieu très symbolique
il ya également aussi le soutien de
dubaï doit non pour ses salariés
absolument et c'est très intéressante
donc ça devient un moment important pour
cette présidence qui a et bouger plus à
gauche qui est devenu de plus en plus
proulx syndicale pendant la campagne
étant donné le soutien des travaillants
la mobilisation des travailleurs est il
y à une loi aujourd'hui devant le
cénacle été voté par la chambre des
représentants qui aiderait à renforcer
les droits de syndicalisation aux états
unis comme vous le savez surtout dans le
sud les lois sont tout à fait
défavorable à la syndicalisation est ce
que
initiative soutenue par le président
américain et ses et c'est assez rare
qu'un président se prononce en faveur de
210 cas aux états unis
est ce que cette initiative peut faire
tache d'huile en europe et ailleurs dans
le monde
toute la question c'est que y'a t'il et
un renouveau syndical
marion que les présidences que les
présidents démocrates se prononce en
faveur des syndicats et des travailleurs
ça ce n'est pas rare le fait qu'ils
agissent concrètement c'est autre chose
donc il faut voir dans quelle mesure les
démocrates vont vraiment défendre le
droit des salariés aux états unis
effectivement la question de renouveau
syndical se posent aux états unis comme
partout dans le monde aggravés encore
une fois par le coroner la russe vers
l'ue ses travers en première ligne parce
que les travers d'amazon était en
première ligne
c'était bien connu et on a une situation
où la fortune de jeff bezos le pdg de
l'entreprise a assez multiplié il a
gagné plus de 70 milliards de plus dans
sa fortune personnelle pendant cette
grève pendant que les travailleurs
continuent à gagner des salaire minimal
donc c'est aussi une question
d'inégalité une égalité qui se posent
mais pourquoi finalement amazon mais
autant d'énergie pour casser cette
initiative de quoi ont-ils peur bassin
amazon c'est la plupart des employeurs
aux états unis en 2019 une étude récente
a montré que plus de 50% des les
employeurs sont engage des violations du
droit syndical pendant les campagnes de
syndicalisation aux états unis c'est une
entreprise qui gagnent des milliards de
dollars les autres les entrepreneurs et
les employeurs sont tout à fait contre
les saints des cas aux états unis chez
malheureusement une tradition et une
culture intersyndicale et surtout dans
le sud où les lois sont partis calmement
défavorable à la syndicalisation est ce
que vous pensez que cette initiative a
une chance d'aboutir le 31 mars prochain
écoutez on ne peut que l'espérer
mais ce n'est pas la première fois qu'il
ya beaucoup d'espoir il ya eu des
campagne de syndicalisation de
volkswagen dans le tennessee deux fois
depuis quelques années aussi nissan dont
le mississippi le problème c'est les
moyens qu'ils ont les ont les employeurs
c'est tout à fait légal pour le moment
d'organiser des réunions obligatoires
pour les salariés où il ya un discours
anti syndicale des menaces des menaces
de licenciement des rendez vous
individuels ont les salariés des
pressions énormes continuer la campagne
contre eux voient le golfe d'aden le
carrément le gouverneur le gouverneur de
l'état s'est mobilisé pour proférer des
propos anti syndicale etc
les pressions sont absolument énorme
donc on espère tous ceux qui sont pour
les syndicats espèrent qu'il va y avoir
ce vote mais les pressions encore une
fois son énorme chute imprévisible
merci beaucoup un sauna kesselman
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes professeur à
l'université paris est créteil
spécialiste des relations de travail aux
etats unis